what makes a good story for me I'm
always saying it's action plus emotion
because the kind of storytelling that I
teach is scripted story storytelling so
we have to see it and we have to feel it
action begets emotion which begets more
action so to me it's the marriage of
these two things where do you see
writers struggling the most when they
come into your classes what are some of
the things they share with you where
they struggle the most is I think
probably this need to to follow rules
and get it right and there are no real
rules and there is no one way to get it
right so I'm always trying to get them
just to express their intention for the
story on pages as best they can if
they've met that intention that's right
you know those are their rules so I
think that's that's that's where I see
artists struggling is you know it's it's
got to be perfect no it doesn't it just
has to be what you want I like that
what can a screenwriter do to get better
at their craft is that is that basically
it to just kind of express that
underlying emotion without trying to be
so perfect and explaining a certain
story that if they were a little more
free with it yeah I do think that there
are you know on the other hand certain
tools and techniques that they can use
for for paring down their work for
focusing their work for making sure that
they're meeting their intentions by
picking the words that best express that
by placing the words where they need to
by really focusing their scenes so that
their scenes tell a story so it's not a
question of oh just be free okay it is a
question of really looking at your art
and making sure that you are telling the
story as best you can
with those intentions in mind I'd say
don't make it perfect because it doesn't
have to be but you do have to spend some
time focusing does it make sense it does
it does is there a point that a writer
should give up on a screenplay
is there a point that a writer should
give up on a screenplay no I you know no
I don't think so because I think you've
all heard those stories of I and then I
put an insurer and then six years later
somebody wanted this or a world event
happened and it was just right so you
might put it aside for the moment
because it's not getting the traction
you want it's it's it's or you yourself
have tired of it and you want to move on
to something else go ahead put it in the
drawer but don't get rid of it that is a
piece of art that will find its way
eventually
you